let's get to our first news story we're
going to talk about moving on from a
breakup it's so hard and it hurts so bad
and even worse
it's um when your instagram looks like
the wallpaper of your ex-life yeah and
best life reports that the dating app
plenty of fish found one-third of daters
say that they delete all photos of their
ex off instagram after a breakup it's
called sanitizing and for many people
it's very cathartic just ask j.lo
because she recently scrubbed her
instagram
of every last trace of a-rod did she
really she totally derotted her
yes yes
yes and i would like to know ross is
your instagram free x-free uh no no it's
not xv this is gonna be a complicated
conversation because i believe you know
your exes are part of you you know
whether you like it or not they become
part of the fabric of who you are like a
tattoo or nacho bell grande they just
become
part of you and i don't think you should
sanitize your instagram i'm in the
relationship i'm in now engaged bt dubs
thanks so much
but i am a fully formed man who knows a
thing or two about life because of my
past relationships i'm so grateful for
them i completely agree i would just
remember there's one i did a race yeah
no there was one
i shouldn't have done it but you know
what you did and you deserved it so
sometimes i think
i think we should all aspire to not want
to
do it but every once in a while you know
they dogs and they deserve it well i
think also maybe you want to scrub your
instagram but just don't allow your
partner to try to make you scrub your
past because that's not that's not
possible that is the preach preach drew
all right well moving on can be hard but
it can also be a cause for a major
celebration listen to this you're gonna
love it uh you know how people put those
signs on their lawns to celebrate
something big like graduating high
school or a birthday well local abc 24
in memphis reports people are putting
out lawn signs to proudly announce other
things like their divorce
take a look at this you can have a lawn
sign
finally the worst
yes
you can celebrate anything you're super
proud of uh happily divorced their sky
is the limit so drew if you put a sign
in your yard today what would it say
well i didn't have to when it came to my
divorce the new york post did that for
me
um
so thank you for taking care of that one
and my sign today would actually be
i don't know how it's possible to be
this happy
oh
that's a good sign
it's true
and listen
there were so many days that wouldn't
have been my sign i fought so hard uh
for that to be my sign but it really is
um all right rossi by the way in our
studio audience who i saw standing
outside i spotted a woman there she is
right there wave hello hi
who is this what's your name hi my name
is amy i'm a teacher from new jersey
and um what did we bond over through the
glass with no words like in a romantic
french film um i just got my drew
barrymore tattoo
no
oh my gosh
and i have one son named drew
[Applause]
i am not
being weird does it have
is it a coincidence
no
[Music]
uh-huh
i've been a fan forever
i also have your oscar dress
wait which one now i i wanted um you put
it up for auction spca like 20 years ago
and i hit on it that when you went to
with ed norton
and i won the dress i spent my entire
paycheck on it and i wore it on my
apartment for years
oh my gosh
yeah
is that crazy
um
you need a better payoff than just this
moment oh my gosh
um
you like maybe you want to come on the
show oh my god yes yes oh my gosh
yes um i i want you to come and uh
co-anchor the news with us yeah oh my
gosh yes
it's an honor to meet you welcome to the
team
thank you everybody
all right
great news for anyone who likes to sit
at home doing voice overs for their dogs
and cats for their own amusement you
know you're not alone the washington
post reports that many pet parents
pretend that their furry family members
can talk and they even have developed
very specific voices for them some say
their dog sounds like cookie monster
and or like a concerned old german man
i sound like heidi klum if i tried to do
a german accent in in fashion you're
either in or you're out
that was good okay and then there's even
like a fancy sort of french person watch
this
okay check me out i am serving dalmatian
of illness cruella would love this one i
feel like an elegant llama but don't
worry i don't spit
that dog is like by the way super fast
yeah
let's look at your dog oh so i have
three dogs take a look and i have
thought about the voices these um so
audrey's in the front and she's a lady
so she sounds like well me
um
in the back in the back that's paw earl
and he's a dork so he's like this like
i'm a dork and then selena's in the
middle and she's like kind of gruff like
this because i think she used to be a
smoker before i died
i love it
[Music]
you